always the first one's the weirdest yep
always
real quick but for now i'm like i'm
sitting on the wrong side
i feel like i'm in europe and i'm
driving the car wrong
[Music]
what's going on there reject nation so
we're going to be doing something
different we're introducing a new
segment to the channel called koi's
comic corner
graphics to come later
implied visuals
cartoon koi there
so yeah we've been trying to find a
segment for koi to do here uh on the
channel that's specifically suited for
him yeah there's gonna be times where
neither myself nor john are in the video
because you'll see how we might be
rendered pointless after a while
i'm gonna hand this off to koi today i
thought it would be fun for you to kick
off your first segment with how the
fantastic four will be introduced into
the mcu take it away koi gendro so i'm
thinking we're gonna talk about the last
time we saw the fantastic four how i
would introduce them into this universe
who i might cast some suggested reading
and even some plot details of where i
think the mcu could bring the fantastic
four marvel's first family feels like a
good place to start with a first episode
of this show it feels very good because
this is something we've been striving
for since the mcu began and arguably
it's one of the first mainstream teams
that the people were aware of this came
out not long after x-men it was not long
after spider-man but it's a coy for your
first segment please don't smack the
microphone i feel like it's needed i
feel like i gotta show it
i'm laying the president i'm an alpha
male i'll give you something
it's like prison you gotta beat up the
biggest guy in the room so i feel like
with the precedent set by obviously
multiverse of madness we will be seeing
them sooner than later i also feel like
it's not a coincidence that they moved
quantum mania up because i do feel like
we're getting not only kang thing look
who did it
i love that i saw peripherally and i
just felt the connection but i feel like
after uh quantomania we're gonna be in a
very different world of the mcu i saw
the video you made about how it's insane
that people think that this is
directionless it's not phase four is not
directionless what's going to happen is
much like civil war i think after
quantum mania there's going to be a big
pivot into where phase 4 is going i
think it's very intentionally open-ended
right now just like phase one started
we're only five movies into phase four i
think the big turn is going to be in
ant-manimos quantomania i think that's
going to yield a fantastic four if not
all of them some of them and i think we
are gonna get at least nods to dr doom
and black panther so i'd say by the end
of the year more fantastic four by the
end of next year all but established
just in time for 2024's fantastic four
but how are they being introduced i feel
like the way to do it is in ant-man and
the wasp you've got the quantum realm
which is very well established and if
you've seen a lot of those theories
there's a small city a la superman small
city in a bottle you've got this tiny
little city i feel like the best way to
show the fantastic four's intelligence
is to have them preserved in time i
would have them trapped in time a la
janet van dyne and have their technology
still advanced from today's technology
imagine a man so intelligent that what
he was inventing in the 60s is available
now that's how you don't have yet
another kind of aloof an overly
intelligent character if you've got
doctor strange and iron man feeling like
each other the last thing you want is
another guy that's like i'm a bit hard
to deal with and very smart you do that
by having a fish out of water story you
have the marvel's first family be
something from the 60s you have it feel
like this weird throwback to a bygone
era and that also differentiates it from
a lot of other marvel team books because
you've got the avengers already well
established you've got young avengers to
come you've got the x-men to come how do
you make marvel's first family feel
different you set them as a fish out of
water story and you make the family
dynamic what brings them closer together
they're the only people from this time
they're stuck together and that's also a
big part of the comic books is johnny
can turn his flames on and off but the
thing is stuck as the thing one of them
is a movie star effectively one of
them's a monster but they're all bonded
together by this family element that
they're adventurers add to that the 60s
element add to that being trapped
together i think it adds another dynamic
to an already incredible story and in
addition to all the 60s stuff of having
them be fish out of water there was that
really subtle drop that really got
overshadowed by everyone cheering in the
movie where doctor strange actually says
didn't you chart in the 60s which is
either a boy band joke or actually is
acknowledging that reed richards was
from the 60s so we might already have
them be canon in our universe by doctor
strange at least knowing and
acknowledging who he is they could play
that either way which is fun about
easter eggs is they could never
acknowledge that again it could be a
joke or it could be the 60s concept of
having krazynski's reed richards already
established which would make that
krazynski canon because doctor strange
wouldn't be like hey there's this guy
that vaguely looks like a stretchy dude
i bet that's reid like you have to be
john krasinski for that joke to work and
there's a lot of rumors that john mayer
may not come back so that would kind of
make it for the plot of your fantastic
four movie or the idea initially upon
introduction is that they've been
trapped in the quantum realm so are you
suggesting that their first movie would
be about them in the 60s prior to them
getting trapped similar to the way how
captain america first avenger was about
him in the 40s and then it ended with
him getting trapped in the ice yeah in
the same vein we've had 40s and 90s with
captain marvel i'd have 60s with
fantastic four i would throw back modern
day and past tens i would use a nihilist
personally we haven't seen annihilus on
screen what is a nihilism annihilus is a
devourer of basically content but
nihilus consumes all not quite to the
level of galactus where it gives energy
but annihilus is a negative zone villain
that is all-consuming all corrupting and
it looks like a giant insect imagine a
very very evil cricket it looks like an
evil green and purple cricket and i
think that villain since we haven't seen
it on screen before and it's kind of not
one note i feel like one note's not fair
but simple it's a simple villain so you
wouldn't have to do a lot of backstory
you could really dive into the family
and then allow this villain to build up
and earn doctor doom i don't think dr
dunes be the main villain for the first
film i think it should be kind of the
emperor palpatine use the nihilist to
give us some story and i would sub the
negative zone concept for the quantum
realm
and then it's kind of plug and play you
just swap out the term negative zone for
quantum realm which is already
established and you got yourself a movie
i think i know what lost city you're
talking about i've heard a lot of people
theorizing that's king's castle i think
it can be king's castle that they're
trapped oh right so therefore you've got
king as something that's been corrupting
them from the beginning you've got kang
as a very doctor doom-esque element and
i love the idea that kang grandfather to
reed richards in many continuities would
be the one keeping them trapped so yeah
we've already met kang that would endear
us to them more and if you do want to
keep john krasinski you could have kang
be the father of sue storm instead of
reed richards that way you still get the
family element and that way you have one
of those twists that marvel likes to do
where it's a twist on comic book fans
expectations it's a little nudge but
then the people in the audience if they
don't know are like oh my god the dad of
like star wars and the people that do
know are like wait that's not the father
and it'd be really fun to play with we
can't reasonably have john krasinski be
the grandson of kang as it stands now
but we could do that with sue okay i
know you mentioned krasinski what would
the cast of this
be so in the comics kang is is often
nathaniel richards who is a time
traveler who's related to reed richards
so the twist would be sue storm and in
some relation whether father grandfather
you could do anything with time travel
we haven't met kang yet we've met he who
remains so we've got an infinite number
of possibilities and i do honestly think
kang is going to be bigger than thanos i
think we're going to see at least 10
kangs throughout these movies and we're
going to get to see the incredible
performances of variations of kang we
met the one who was a bit altruistic
while still a villain with that
shakespearean goodness so what i would
do is if we go with kang being the twist
related to sue storm i'd love to see
someone like alexis louder who's in cop
shop who is my dreamcast for storm but i
i think she's very capable she's got an
intelligence tour she's got this whip
smart attitude that i think needs to
keep up with read the beautiful thing
about reed and sue is that reed is the
most intelligent man on the planet and
sue keeps up and is often smarter
because she's got street smarts that
reed doesn't have so just because he's
the smartest man on the planet doesn't
mean you know sue's in the kitchen she's
an incredibly smart woman who also is
able to fight who navigates family
arguably she's the thing that keeps them
all together and you need someone that
shows profound intelligence capability
all of those things and i think alexis
louder is absolutely that if you do the
thing everyone wants as far as the
cliche obviously emily blunt like emily
blunt and john krzezinski that might be
the only way we get emily blunt in the
mcu still he's the daughter of king
still the daughter he's still the dark
how we'll figure it out but if john
krasinski does end up directing then you
have the quiet place situation an entire
family dynamic already built in and they
seem obviously like a couple but they're
also very paternal and maternal so that
would add a lot of good elements to
eventually having franklin richards
eventually growing out the family and i
could easily see emily blunt having to
deal with a zac efron or jacob
montgomery uh human torch there's also
what's a homeboy from um blond dude
really pretty always pops up he's in
game night um he's got like piercing
blue eyes he's kind of snarky but he
plays a villain sometimes his imdb isn't
up here but his name is not that guy i
would also it's just a graphic just
somebody put up a graphic so i can be
shaped into this later he'd be a great
human torch as well but you need human
torch to be someone who he's a hothead
but he has to grow you need his ark to
develop what you love about human torch
is that he's your eye line into the
fantastic four because everyone wants to
be cool but he actually matures as a
person throughout the journey he's kind
of like the anti-peter parker peter
parker puts on his mask and gets
confidence human torch d flames and
learns to grow so his confidence is real
instead of fake like his confidence is
hot air and therefore he has to grow as
a person to be confident for real so i'd
love to see someone with some depth that
seems like they're just on the surface
which is why dr montgomery is so great
because that dude played such a good
villain he was so interesting did i yeah
yeah there it is it's just stranger
things from yeah but i was talking about
three i gave three there's one more guy
that i can't think of yeah i'll make
myself use what's his name by looking up
from everyone how do you keep talking
coins
okay so finally i would say the great
joel edgerton as the thing i think joel
edgerton he's got a soft compassion
about him but also when he's angry you
feel through that i think his eyes are
really gentle which really need to be
for the thing yeah billy magnussen how
good of a human torch would he be uh
he'd be great if i remembered anything
he did but yeah he'd be perfect
magnusson heard some such things greg's
seen as igb and other movies and then
joel edgerton as thing he's got the
build for it he's got that new york
attitude when he wants to the soft
gentle eyes juxtaposing the orange rock
facade very important you also want to
feel compassion for him when he's like
reed you did this to me i'm stuck like
this and i think joel edgerton has so
much heart on his sleeve that you'll
feel that heart through the rocky
exterior and we obviously need to talk
about doctor doom but as i think he's
going to be introduced in black panther
i want to wrap around the idea of more
of a political figure ambassador how
they're going to lay that out so that's
going to be a whole separate video
because i do have some ideas of how
doctor doom specifically ties into black
panther and some casting ideas way to
tease a false
video it's a pilot ladies
and
gentlemen
got in on a cliffhanger with a pilot i
watch tv recommend some reading material
i got you in modern continuity one of my
favorite runs of all time is mark wade
and mike ringo this is a run that lasts
years it is dozens and dozens of issues
and mike ringo to me is one of the best
artists that's ever worked on fantastic
four cause his energy in his frames are
so kinetic they're so high energy it's
almost uh surrealistic to the level of
cartoony it's almost like a saturday
morning cartoon but it's more photo
realistic than saturday morning cartoons
that actually ties really well into that
60s concept i'd also say the current run
by dan slott what he's doing with
fantastic four some of his best work it
gives you a lot more franklin richards
it gives you a lot more the family
dynamic it plays around with human torch
as someone that's trapped as the torch
he can't deflame right now and there's
some really interesting doctor doom
stuff and of course i would recommend
going back to the very beginning i think
going back to the source material uh
mole man introduction all the way back
to the jump fantastic four came out in
the early 60s this predates most comic
books if you look at modern comic books
they owe a lot to the fantastic four so
i would say going back to stan lee's
original fantastic four number one which
you can read digitally they've
re-mastered it a number of time picking
up one of those big essential novels is
absolutely a good time and if you don't
find that as approachable the ultimate
stuff i think is where we're eventually
going ultimate fantastic four original
stan lee fantastic four most recommended
as mark wade and mike ringo as well as
the current dan slot run is what i would
recommend there's a lot of other stuff
but again we'll talk about that more
when it pertains specifically to other
videos and ideas wow comics so the next
video i'm i'm just going to be off to
the side
hey you told me who billy magnuson was
ask
talk about this
what about comics i was going to get
stuck who would play
john malkovich or i'm just going to
create a split screen and loot me
nodding oh yeah that's good stop hitting
the mic just like you have little signs
you hold up little flags all right guys
well here's what we can do why don't you
go ahead and suggest some topics that
maybe koi can cover as we're finessing
this eventually it'll just be him on
camera holding the fort down we'll see
how the moment john goes we'll see
like maybe not
like this one went one way this is
actually
better too maybe maybe people need coins
person not
we'll see you guys subscribe let's catch
you soon it's good to be here